my name is Miriam Levine and I'm a
Survivor of two concentration camps here
in the city of Buenos Aires and I was
kidnapped after the military coup I was
tortured I was held in captivity for
almost two years
back in
2007 I was an investigative reporter
when this Italian
journalist photographer called me he
says have you ever thought we are the
death flight
planes and he said I'm convinced that
identifying the planes we could could
identify the pilots
and the pilots were murderers I started
working with shankarlocharado and after
a few weeks we were able to locate the
planes that participated in the dead
flies
we located the electras
and we located the sky Vans we found
their uh the flight Logs with all the
information all the history of the plane
and that is the plane
from where the bodies of the founders of
mothers of Plaza de Maggio and two
French nuns who were working helping
them were thrown to the ocean the fact
that this plane is coming back to
Argentina is going to be exhibited at
the site of memory of the school of Navy
mechanics
um is is a strong symbol
for the new generations you ought to
remember the crimes that happen in this
country so that we can be sure
that in the next Generations
the defense of democracy is going to be
steady